Parsons with us Carson's in Utah hi
Carson welcome to the Dave Ramsey show I
think Steve my question is that my wife
and I are currently on baby set to work
in our debt snowball and just with
everything that's kind of going on we're
wondering if maybe we should add up our
emergency fund a little bit where we
have five children at home well know
with everything that's going on if you
are struggling with career or you have a
potential problem because of carna virus
with your career you don't need to be
doing the baby steps you would just stop
push pause and pile up cash until the
storm blows by and then you'll be
concerned about that right now okay I
thought you said with everything that's
going on well you are concerned nowhere
I have five kids if something were to
happen well five kids is one thing but
and in that case you know if you want to
build up that emergency fund a little
bit listen here's the thing I want baby
step one and it's intentionally small to
be uncomfortable how much money do you
have in savings now ah now about three
thousand okay how long have you had
money in savings just recently because
we got our tax return and all and I know
that I need to adjust that so most of
them comes back to me directly yes
absolutely
okay but my point is you're not you've
been my getting with five kids with no
savings anyway true it's nothing
different now so I mean if you want to
leave it at two and throw one I mean I
wouldn't have it more than double a baby
step one though one thousand is not
designed to be enough it's designed to
catch a little emergency and it's
designed to keep you uncomfortable until
you get your debts paid so that you're
focused and intense and sacrificial in
your lifestyle and getting your debts
paid you probably don't have a glamorous
lifestyle you're feeding a lot of baby
birds but so how much debt do you have
not counting your home about seventeen
thousand at about ten thousand on a
vehicle and seven thousand student your
household income right now it's about
40,000 at the end of the year should be
stopped about 48 that's 50,000 take-home
okay cool
how old are the babies was a page range
um my youngest is in preschool and my
oldest is 12 okay all right well I
suspect you're gonna be doing something
to earn some extra income to knock this
out even faster because you've not got a
lot of wiggle room in this budget
feeding five kids that age with a forty
five or forty thousand dollar income
there's not a lot of wiggle room you're
not you're not irresponsible and
overspending yuppie or some kind I mean
you're you're just barely cutting it and
so in order to knock that 17 out you're
gonna need an extra thousand fifteen
hundred dollars a month coming from
somewhere to get rid of that you can get
rid of in about a year if you do that
okay and soon as you get that stuff off
your back then your budgets going to
have a little more room and you'll be
able to go ahead and build your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses so if you want to hold that
baby step one at two thousand that's
okay it's not the other world the point
though is and I want everybody here this
baby step one is supposed to make you
uncomfortable it's supposed to be not
enough it's supposed to make you worried
that if there's an emergency you can't
cover it because it's not so that you
get your butt out of debt because I want
you to bust through that with intensity
and that's what we're doing here hold on
Carson I'm going to have a Zak pick up
and send you a copy of the Total Money
Makeover book to help you guys get
through this we want to make sure we're
there with you and we appreciate you
listening sir